benji has been looking into i overheard
this
benji's looking into a leg lengthening
operation in germany
where they can actually lengthen your
legs but i think that's only in children
yeah he might be out of the age range
what have you looked into benji what's
going on i mean that this is going to
probably be very sticky but
have you really looked into this i
yeah i uh i haven't i i've thought about
it just because i
when i was younger i didn't realize like
height made a difference and i'm not
short i'm just like i'm average height
what are you exactly
five what i on dating profiles i say
five nine i'm five eight but wouldn't
you wouldn't you bother to just get your
stomach stapled before you got your legs
lengthened
i mean i it was me that's what i do well
you know somebody say
taller people can carry more weight
that's what right
they do stretch out your legs and i
don't think i think they can eat at any
age
it's really but it's supposed to be you
know
it doesn't all i don't think it always
comes out right but they do
they stretch out i think they break your
legs and stretch them out and it takes
about two years to get the new height
are you convinced that the reason you're
not getting women
or the women you want is because you're
too short yeah it's not true
oh yeah you've said it sometimes i don't
but sometimes i do it's not like an
always kind of thing but you're the one
who thinks if you put your mind to it
you could get any woman you want first
of all i'd like to debate that
when i was like a little kid i remember
i had like a cardboard box
and i really wanted to make a tv and my
mom said to me like
i really i had a cardboard box and
aluminum foil
and my mom was like i really if you
really work hard at it i think you can
do it
like you can do anything i think that's
was instilled in me
i see well according to the
international center for limb
lengthening to be considered you have to
be a healthy
non-smoker who has reached complete
skeletal maturity
and the total recommend lengthening is
two to three inches so if he's five
eight they can bring him up
maybe two inches three inches i don't
think it's worth it
instead of lengthening the legs i don't
know why they don't just put implants in
your heels
and that's why i started wearing those
shoes for a while
yeah like why don't you wear like a high
heels or just you know like they could
no but they could just
they could just stick that in your foot
like ins inside the skin so you would
just have it
okay well why don't you get that once
you talk to a doctor about that
i i guess i will like big platforms but
put them under your skin
and yeah
could you put step ladders in my ankles